I've got an assignment for you if you're
planning your social media campaign
you're trying to get more followers
you're trying to get more exposure on on
social media the next time that you're
feeling upset angry inspired enlightened
happy depressed whatever it is the next
time you're feeling a heightened emotion
I want you to pull out your phone and
tweet about it and put it on Facebook
because I guarantee you that that one
post will get more shares more likes
more people talking about it more
engagement than anything you've ever
created those are the kinds of posts
that you want to put on social media I
have a scheduled calendar that goes out
on social media and I'll share pictures
and quotes and inspire me and all sorts
of different stuff but the ones that get
the most impact army in the moment
frustrated about something happy about
something angry about something and you
want to get in the practice of sharing
that make it personal when you make it
personal people will care and when you
start seeing results you want to do it
more and you may be thinking well my
business isn't personal it's about the
business I tweet about business stuff
nobody cares about that stuff nobody
will care your company will never become
successful on social media as long as
you are sharing boring business stuff
you have to make it personal if you
don't make it personal your accounts are
dead nobody connects with an icon that
connect with you and they want to know
what you stand for what you believe in
and what makes you tick that's what you
need to share and I know it's hard and
it's and it's vulnerable and it's real
and you'll be thinking what would people
think about me but you got to do it at
least once try it once okay you may be
thinking Evan that's crazy I can never
do that it's unprofessional just do once
do it once your assignment for the week
is to do one emotion-filled tweet and
Facebook posts based on something that's
happening in the moment right now you're
upset about something you're in start
about something post it right now that's
what you need to put up do it once and
when you see the results from that
you want to do it again homework for the
week believe does he watching like the
video thumbs up below thank you so much
and let me know you think leave a
comment I love seeing your comments come
in i read each one leave a question for
me i'll make a video response thank you
so much and I'll see you soon